[Music]
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play death dice
over note as you may recall I'm not
feeling 100%
well right now I'm feeling 110 percent
because they took like ten day quills
and some mucinex super EXTREME that had
like 14 ingredients in it I probably was
supposed to take it but oh well who
cares that's what this game is all about
right or dose dad I played before I'm
not gonna lie I've played it before so I
won't worry about it
so this game it's look at the pretty
color look at all okay so this game is I
can jump real high wait no I wait what
okay so this game has got sorry I got
something in my throat from you know
being stick getting there getting where
I don't even know okay let me know I'll
play so you play this game and you're
trying to oh you're trying to get to the
my brain is not working okay wow you
squished my brain okay so you trying to
get that Emmet's in the gods gambling
against you sort of thing because that's
a thing that happens yeah the gods are
gambling against you while you sit at
this measly bus stop probably cuz they
think they're just a giant douche pool
who's it just an [ __ ] oh sorry sorry
okay so you're this asinine nobody with
a tie you know one of those suits that
go about their day live and don't play
video games Wow what am I talking about
I don't even know anymore so the gods
are gambling yeah the gods are gambling
against you the kana maybe skipped over
that part but you're a freakin druggie
oh no okay that's okay it's no big deal
your friggin druggie whoa no you try to
get your pills to make you forget this
horrible nightmare but you it won't
happen that's why I was drawn to this
game because this guy's popping I spit
all over the screen sorry screams
phantom not sorry sorry not sorry
okay whatever these are the jokes jokes
these are the jokes okay so that
exploded and I don't know what happens
if you get pills enough to make them to
make the black bar go all the way black
see when you're in the white everything
seems to be kind of normal news just
derping out look at them dancing stupid
dance with the corrosion yeah I don't
know what happens if the bar goes all
the way white or left I think if it goes
white you die I was brought very close
to that I have no idea but I need to get
enough to get to the black but that's
what I'm gonna end this playthrough I
have many games that I want to play but
I want to be able to take them seriously
oh my black bars huge everybody look at
how big my black bar is nothing nothing
innuendo he about that oh my bar it's so
big
[Music]
I had it don't tell me it wasn't bad it
wasn't good either ah ah I got this I
got this
I gotta get it my black bar it's getting
get hard to get it up
I mean gah boom I'm gonna him there
aren't enough pills here where's Lewis
when you need him
do you know Lewis from left 4 dead with
the pills here oh that I think that I
think that tornado actually saved me way
to go tornado buddy
oh no just let me stick Dan gloomy I
love the way that he just derps around
just a druggie office I bet I've been in
real life people are looking at him on
the bus top he's like Forrest Gump but
instead of a box of chocolates he's got
a box of cocaine and he's just slamming
down pills of cocaine as he goes along
his day no no again come on I've almost
got my black bar all the way I don't
know what happens I know they said
something weird happens I want to know
give me the pal there we go I got this
couple pal oh no I'm okay
I got that stuff freaking out over
nothing
time just was close don't be blowing up
almost blew me up gods please stop
gambling away everything of my life
because I need to get these pills super
jump
it caught me off guard God like all the
way out bah gah gah gotta get this ahh
hey you guys don't even know what I'm
talking about saying a black bar maybe
you guys don't even know that one
explained much in this game I just
started playing and I don't know don't
look at me like that don't look at me
I just want to go to bed I can't even
get enough pills but I made a promise
that I would okay good start lots of
pills here lots of pills here ah that
was dumb dumb Maya I'm dumb I'm filled
with dumb don't judge me
oh dear oh dear you fail oh oh dear Zin
OD AHA I am a heroin gum forest forest
heroin gun his long-lost bait was cut a
chapter out of the from the book did you
know a Forrest Gump was originally a
book and it was much worse than the
movie apparently but Tom Hanks genius
and stuff and he went to like the moon
or something I forget he did a lot of
more stuff in the book and he fit in the
movie
look seriously when having this spacer I
don't know there's all this a bunch of
nonsense first super dumb oh come on
this is normal life I need to get I need
to get it this may take a while guys
yes that's a bonus pills give me more
give me more I got I got maybe if I let
the pills build up instead of getting
him right away
maybe that's the ticket don't be a
blow-up oh no I don't think it works I
think the pills don't spawn until I get
him and I gotta get him quickly oh I'm
almost oh I think of my bar goes all the
way why'd I lose there was a lot before
and now there's nine oh I got a headache
all the colors flashing lights seizure
warning
I guess not really there aren't really
flashing colors here I don't think this
Oh how dumb am i stupidly dumb dumb very
with the dumb I don't care about the up
one it's dumb dude am god's betting on
my life is this really worth it
what are you having betting on up there
you gambling addict God's up there on a
Mount Olympus looking boy I just don't
it's the truth in the background
notice that tree that is an awesome tree
look he's just swaying back and forth
for the music I just now looking at the
clouds they got oh where are my pals Oh
God I I can't I can't
I can't handle this I can handle it give
me my pills God there aren't enough
pills
don't be a blowie ob/ob a blow a bee
oh my computer is lagging from the
amount of everything that's going on I
was gonna get it there was so many pills
lined up the tree was all like you got
odds few went away now I'm sad bagging
what is that have I seen that before no
I recognize it oh well good okay just
give me my pills let me go on my daily
life all right
throat aah shouldn't be screaming like
this Oh bring it on tornado [ __ ] call
you call you an f0 o yf0 is game racing
kind of falcon punch whatever you know
you know all that I can't believe this
I'm so bad my brain is not working I'm
making very cool there's no bells come
on bring it on you ball my big black bar
can take on your big black ball any day
and a match of skill contest of skill
miss me dick my bar it's so small yeah
I don't get it sometimes there's really
just shut up a bit sometimes Oh
[Music]
oh god I'm almost there please give me
more pills please give me more pills
that's a lot of dice right now why so
many dice one of them better be pills
oh I made it okay I'm okay
ah give me more pills man came is
slowing down my computer is not good
enough to handle it apparently or maybe
it's always been this slow I don't know
maybe my brain is slowing down
maybe I'm killing my brain cells slowly
ah I didn't really take as much cold
medicine as I said that was what you
would call an exaggeration for a more
dramatic effect but what I want to take
more of is these goddamn pills I want to
dance like an epileptic squid on acid is
that part of this round you know what I
think the game is just ice I indeed
think the game is slowed down I need to
I need to reboot the game that is
problem start over
yes now we're going just as slowly oh my
god I just wanna
how my throat really hurts why everyone
restarting everything ah no you're
[ __ ] ads who gives an ass about
adventure quest no one that's room like
2001 people stop giving a [ __ ] about
that back before I was born
[ __ ] you god damn it very upset thank
you for that quality down plan yes good
oh now we're full speeds for some reason
they apparently didn't expect anyone to
actually play this as much as I am
though fu and they and have a nice day
did this get louder it got louder you
know uncle markiplier says eff you in
the a and have a nice day bad day just
give me my pills
give me my gosh dingdong dabbling pills
my pills I'm going to have such a nap
after this
oh so many pills
what's up there wait what
[Music]
my black bar was up there it did nothing
was alive maybe I read it wrong
committee is lying ah Oh what what are
you doing now what are you doing
what the hell I don't even know oh you
know what
I'm let go my head really hurts
probably from screaming so much ah man
I need to do I need to take a nap
I'm really tired I don't know what it's
doing anymore oh no no no I'm done with
it done with you never done with you
guys cuz I love you Tessa's but I put
myself through to give you guys
entertainment let's see what it probably
wasn't I don't know
I'm sweaty and tired I'm gonna take a
nap okay all right you all them
beautiful shining stars
remember what uncle markiplier says have
you in the a and have a nice day
[Music]
you